all right so I want to take the first
couple minutes of this video to just
blog pieces of pastiche at the moment
you might know a piece of this TV also
makes roller coaster in three videos
it's really awesome go check him out but
what's even better is that he made this
bridge which you might see over here
while if you don't see it you must be
blind or something and no offense but
it's gonna be hard to see it and in case
that bridge was actually built by piece
of the stage I didn't record the process
of me building it since it was just a
tiny bit of a test he I was just
streaming at the time when I was
building this entire section of the park
as I usually am and during the stream
actually he gave me this bridge so I
decided to close down rollercoaster get
three get it up again and see how the
bridge would work and as you can sell it
looks absolutely amazing
and the download is up so I'm going to
need to put that in the description of
this video now knowing me I'm probably
gonna forget that so if I do please
remind me that I need to put the link in
the description but yeah that's that's
sort of why I didn't film the creation
of that bridge but in the end it did
really matter that getting that bridge
in there a really good fitting Dutch
bridge which it turned out to really be
was just a big help to the entire thing
also one good reason why I didn't want
it to be filmed was that I completely
failed building the bridge you like has
it got that bridge it may be one bridge
but it's made out of different separate
sections and I completely derped on
trying to place those right so I was a
bit awkward
then entirely once again that nine the
video in any case here is more detail
work I know this Astana's got boring but
I have something to really say about
this park so far I have just been doing
the basic things getting the basic
buildings in there just doing all sorts
of things that I really like hop from
one thing to the other finish some nice
little attractions and all such things
but like the in-between little touches
to the park so far I've sort of left
alone so the next couple of episodes are
going to be finishing up details are
going through news sets just exploring
things see what sort of items I need to
get in there I think some extra details
two buildings like this building for
example I was alright with the overall
shape and how it was over there but it
was really lacking a tiny bit of detail
to make it not just stand out from the
Main Street
self but also stand out from other
buildings that use the same sets because
I don't really like to have buildings in
which you can clearly just realize the
pieces that have been used in it and
that nothing really creative has been
done with them so especially with this
sort of thing there are many custom
scenery sets out there with those little
wooden stuff little wooden cornices and
whatever you can really place anywhere
and say those ferocious by the way
arches are an amazing thing which you
can just stack really because and like
many custom scenery sets and get some
really unique artworks in there so that
was also something that I wanted to do
over here and that's basically also why
these episodes aren't going to be the
most spectacular sort of things since
the quote-unquote spectacular stuff has
already been done the train station was
a lot of fun to make and I'm really
happy about how it turned out just
overall the log flume area same goes for
that but I really just loved some very
small things that I wasn't quite feeling
like doing because honestly they're not
that interesting
I sort of just left those to pretty much
die and I just need to get to it right
here that's basically that so I taught
my story and I'll be way too quickly I
think I was talking like way too fast
over there doesn't really matter it's
just random little details not even much
to it really just like I said skimming
through sets and finding out whatever
could really work this also did result
in some time lapses which just turned
into you know me scrolling through sets
seeing if there's anything good anywhere
just trying pieces out and see if it
really works somewhere and yeah I
normally wouldn't really like to do that
but the entire premise of this entire
series is to stuff I build a park and
film the entire while the entire just
making of that Pike so yeah the less fun
parts are also part of the making of
this bike so that's why I decided to
keep them in so that's what these
episodes are going to be like that being
said in the future like after I finish
all that stuff this is not the only
things I don't want to just add little
details to buildings I still need to do
a tiny bit of both work here in there
finish up the river area
and just get some I want also to get a
trolley track around this little Main
Street not entirely sure how that's
gonna happen excited to have the trolley
track I'm not entirely sure on the
station and things like that I still
need to research that for a time but
once I get all of those things done I
should be able to move into the English
area confident that I can actually do
some good stuff in there I have actually
already researched the tiny bit of the
architecture and got some ideas of what
I want to do there and I actually think
that I do want to do a Benham stand up I
know that it's a really uncommon idea
especially since no while bnm /
internment stand up has really ever been
themed in any sort of way that's
actually sort of why I want to try it I
want to see if I can actually make that
work
once you've just got a tiny bit of a
unique sort of attraction in there I
know that sounds incredibly hipster but
I and there is just I know this also
sounds really stupid but I just felt
like an English coaster would be an
intimate standup and this is entirely
just ripped from Drayton Manor but I
just feel like that would be the sort of
thing that would work there and I don't
know if I want to place a mind train
over there since I feel like the Alpine
area would be a better area for the mind
train I feel like the East Asian area
would be the best place to have a bnm
inverts and reasons like that is
basically why I just sort of left the
the intimate stand up to be built in the
English area it's not one of the best
rollercoasters out there but I wanted to
preserve the best roller coasters for
other theme it's not to mention the
English areas should hopefully still get
a dark ride of sorts so in the end it
should be an alright area and it's
definitely not gonna just be really tiny
in comparison to the Mediterranean area
that should all be rights and I'm also
worried about that really so and there's
that plan and then there's the fact that
the hundred and they like episode 100 is
going to be coming up and I'm not
entirely sure what I want to do with
that if I do plan it right I might get
episode 100 up just in the weekend just
before I go to university so I still
have some time to do things so that
means that I'm gonna have to be
releasing the other videos in this sort
of very short time scale which should
actually
all right and then if I do do that
stream it's gonna be a tiny bit of a
special stream since I usually open bar
I always stream on Twitch it's just a
better service but a tiny bit of a let's
play livestream I think wouldn't really
hurts I'm not sure about how much I like
it the entire sort of time-lapse theme
to be broken in that episode but I think
it's a good compromise between getting a
special episode in and also getting
actually to do something in the park
because as much as I want to do a
special episode for episode 100 it is
quite a mild stuff really [ __ ] 100
episodes of all across the country and I
still haven't [ __ ] stopped and people
still aren't not interested anymore so
that's all really a huge feat but I
don't want to get an episode in in which
I do nothing at all in which I don't
really do anything about the pike so I
still want to do something useful in
that so like a stream would work on that
also tiny bit of trivia over here as I
am placing these rocks and you might
notice that those are in-game rocks and
those are one of the few exceptions
really there is almost a bit over taboo
when it comes to using the in-game
things but there's a couple of things
that I really just like there is that
I'm not entirely sure what it's called
but there is one grassy looking shrub in
the western theme that is a very good
in-game foliage thing that I have
actually seen people use quite often and
I've actually used in the past as well
but my favorite in-game piece is
probably actually those rocks having
those recoverable rocks without very
light texture it just blends so
perfectly with the waverers launchbox
that I just really had to use it and get
a tiny bit more of the brown shade in
there but yeah my video is synchronized
by the way I just took way too long to
to really talk about that after it's
already happened I am at this point
really doing the catwalks over there by
the way I did get many questions about
those catwalks I was forced to do
something unorthodox over there because
wooden catwalks aren't the most common
thing so these catwalks are a
combination of big burgers timber which
is just the Mowbray steel jungle
equivalent of wooden supports you can do
wooden supports with it for coasters but
you can do practically anything with it
we make buildings or make catwalks
whatever you really come up with you can
do many things with big burgers timber
so always like to kind of experiment
with that and the stairs over there are
from station gym scaffolding it's not my
usual go-to sort of sets for this thing
but I didn't realize that I had some
really good fences and it had the
diagonal pieces using which I could make
that curve on top of this which does
look a tiny bit wonky doesn't really
match the curve of the log flume but
then again that's something I also sort
of liked about it only real thing is
that it's a tiny bit unrealistic in a
sense that people there is quite a gap
in between the station and the plant but
no that was quite a gap in between the
the flume boats and the catwalks over
there but yeah that's that's me I think
my looks are more important than the
realism of this Pike plus who who's
gonna have to evacuate people off of the
log flume there's a doesn't live so
right behind that like this isn't
[ __ ] Japan we don't have to have
sidewalks anyway
I mean catwalks but I see now I'm
running out at the time has one last
thing that I wanted to say the reeds are
absolutely Bay if you have any sort of
pond or even a small lake or anything
get some reeds in there and make sure to
mix them with other foliage maybe the
beach cross set since the reeds on their
own they're just really thin really
narrow and don't really work out too
well on their own but if you mix the
well with other sets and make it look
more like a real life sort of reed
forest they can really work very well
but yeah that's that just a tiny bit of
lily pad coverage over here but in the
end I did put more lily pads in there
because this was just not even you know
if you couldn't really see them well but
yeah I'm definitely running out of time
over here so that's gonna be the end of
this video I'll see you guys in the next
video and I am sorry that I've been
talking way too fast this video no no
entirely sure how that happened but yeah
I know the case thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys later